Let's go next to our caller from the two zero
one area code.
Who's calling today from two Oh one
Hey David.
It's Elias Matthews from Buffalo, New York.
Hey Elias, what's going on?
Uh, nothing much.
Uh, so normally, uh, I would just ask a question,
but I have two questions and I don't want
to take up too much of your time, so I'm just
gonna ask, uh, would you rather me ask the
Medicare for all question or a question about
the mentally ill?
I'll let you pick.
Uh, you get, give me the Medicare question.
Okay.
So, um, if Bernie does become president, how
would she implement Medicare for all?
Could he do it through executive order?
Like how, how would he go about doing so?
Well, he would have to do it by getting the
house and Senate to pass it.
And this is going to be one of the difficulties.
Um, I, I have to be careful because my audience
becomes furious with me when I say that.
It's actually going to be way tougher than
almost
anyone on the left is a, I'm willing to admit.
Uh, but no, it's not going to be executive
orders.
It's going to have to be by actually getting
the house and Senate to agree and that will
likely require some negotiation.
Okay.
Do you think that we should negotiate for
like a public auction or do you think that
we should definitely get Medicare for all?
Do you think we should, I don't know what,
like what we would negotiate with is what
I'm saying.
Yeah.
You don't know what, where we were, the negotiation
might end up, I am not going.
So if I say now that we should settle for
something less than a, I will be accused of
being defeatist.
So what I think should happen is Bernie should
campaign on what his ideal policy is.
If people like ideal policy, they should vote
for Bernie.
If Bernie's president at that point, given
whatever house and Senate there is, Bernie
can start the process of trying to get Medicare
for all.
Once we determine what the opposition is to
it, then negotiations can take place.
But I think to prejudge where the negotiations
will end up now doesn't really make sense.
All right, cool.
Thank you.
May ask another quick question.
Sure.
Uh, how do you decide which calls become your
videos?
All of them do.
We don't decide.
We just put the, they all do.
Oh, they all do.
Yeah.
Okay.
You just all do.
Okay, cool.
Yeah.
All right.
Have a good day, David.
Keep up the good work.
Your stuff is great.
All right.
Thank you Elias from Buffalo, Elias from Buffalo.
Absolutely killing it.